hello and welcome to 0 plane match p
from the UK and got a zero score against
them I mean fifty percent score zero
adds sounds so weird it's fifty percent
let's see what we get in the news oh
there he goes further and the main line
with c 596 m and I don't know that's so
well I mean I mostly playing this by ear
so I hope it it works out fine yeah I
know that we should have for what we
need to loop d1 are the moves but I
don't know any specifics okay maybe
rookie one using that pin and here i can
take and play Bishop f4 which is
somewhat annoying and comes back ok so
for out for bishops is six question is
if i should play Bishop t6e or not I
think I should let's take him well let's
let's go for this and be ready to take
on d6
now the structure is awful but white is
very active in TM and probably winning
this porn even though it's not clear
that it is such a great porn I have c5
though this is interesting maybe this is
interesting planning oak 81 next I can
establish a pawn on d6 that would be
pretty neat that looks good that looks
like a good position
and tough to play from luck I mean I can
still take c6 it's not an option that is
unavailable now but this is clearly
putting more pressure on black than just
grabbing on c6 oh wow why does that work
Queen takes c6 looks it's not Queen
takes Queen takes Rupert e8 create TX
takes c6 king of 87 it Chloe it doesn't
work well it's close very close you can
also take everything takes is 6 and
let's let's think about what here it
really looks like um there should be
something absolutely the size of here
maybe just take everything I mean if I
if I get c6 Chapman the queen is
covering the checks on the on the
diagonal so ok it's prevent any age
force
yeah take things this should win right
or not let's think for moved here queen
d six tix there takes tix immediately
between f6c six takes 70 doesn't even
have a check so let's do that
it should to promote actually so ok ok
ok ok so this one maybe 27 I can take g5
and play Queen D cell ok I didn't see
that one coming I can check the check
and place the seven next for Queen the
eighth and promotion
yeah okay 28 yeah there no important yes
is there anything yeah that really went
downhill very quick from the opening
here black is under under some pressure
but it shouldn't be shouldn't be that
decisive not sure here may be taken
maybe taking it's not that great and
this is not the reason for his defeat
I'm just saying that probably maybe this
is better here I don't know why tell
some pressure cooker be one is a move
for example now or take andrew t6 this
route 26 also interesting okay and now
here this looks so comfortable and this
and now c5 and this is already a problem
i think he is in trouble already he has
a hard time to avoid taking on d6 and if
I get this pawn to d6 it's it's going to
be very dangerous and and yeah I think
this is using actually yeah here I
wasn't sure the computer gives this I
wasn't completely sure this is a win
just this and then I saw I saw this and
king of a and this and King e7 and this
is not good am so this is not the not
the trick but I can do this problem and
go here yeah this is also very good
route ending up okay the computer has
certainly right here why does a lot
better in that room bending jagged okay
i think what i did is also pretty strong
i think this should be a win he has to
lose some time due to his wig back rank
and i'm just utilizing the sea por now
he should do and he should have no Jack
defense against that and I'm just
promoting the pawn so a very good
opening opening result here in that
that namazu Indian black or under quick
pressure and couldn't really stand it
okay well thanks for watching